there are a lot of horror movies that
are best seen just once but every now
and again a movie comes along that's not
only rewatchable but enjoying it a
second or third time is necessary to get
the full experience here's some all-time
classic horror flicks definitely worth
screening again and again the guests
boasting killer performances by Dan
Stevens and my eco Munro the guest
features a mysterious young man showing
up on a family's doorstep claiming to
have served in the military with her
recently deceased son he quickly becomes
integral to their family dynamic
but the children suspect he may be
hiding something between the stunning
cinematography and ratcheting levels of
intensity the guest is one of those rare
horror films that allows its ursus
moments to linger just beyond your
expectation until it reaches its intense
climax it's worth revisiting over and
over both as a study and effective genre
experimentation and for the sheer fun of
the central performances of the film The
Shining to say that the shining is
director Stanley Kubrick's magnum opus
is a discredit to the other films in his
unparalleled catalog but it's certainly
one of his finest works adapted from the
Stephen King novel of the same name The
Shining is a cinematic tightening every
frame is significant
featuring Kubrick's signature visual
flair a career-best performance by Jack
Nicholson and a multitude of thematic
ideas and elements it's a layered film
that benefits from multiple viewings
largely due to how much there is to
interpret from the ambiguous ending to
the larger concepts being explored amid
all the jump scares this movie will rank
highly in any film school syllabus for
generations to come the house of the
devil it's tough for a film to strike a
good balance between being fun and being
genuinely frightening and it takes a
director with a deft hand to pull it off
but ty West managed it with house of the
devil
a modern throwback to horror cinema of
the 70s and 80s the film has the
familiar premise of a babysitting gig
gone wrong but tells the story better
than it's been handled in ages thanks to
its grainy aesthetic it feels like an
authentic film from the era but it
diverts from the norm and its lack of
reliance on jump scares or plot
contrivance --is and instead plays out
in the slow burn fashion paying off in a
horrifying finale
yes it's partially worth revisiting just
to see how much of the ending is
telegraphed early on and it's also just
an old-fashioned good time it's the kind
of movie you want to show to friends who
have never heard of it just to see their
reactions a night
Elm Street Wes Craven's original and
Nightmare on Elm Street still works even
all these years later
don't let the countless lousy sequels
distract you from the fact that Freddy
Krueger's first cinematic outing is
funny engaging and scary to boot when a
group of friends realize they're all
having the same dream about a scarred
man with knives four fingers coming
after them they find themselves being
pursued by a killer that exists in the
world of dreams but is still capable of
causing plenty of damage in the real
world the freights are just as potent as
they were decades ago and some of the
effects will still leave viewers
wondering how the filmmakers pulled them
off in such a small budget a Nightmare
on Elm Street is essential viewing and
few slasher films have aged as well as
this one
phantasm shot and disjointed bits and
pieces over the course of a year 1979's
phantasm still came together as one of
the most memorable horror movies of all
time but the film's difficult shoot may
have actually helped make it so
memorable
phantasm more than any other horror
movie captures the feeling of a
nightmare perfectly there's an off tilt
flow to it not everything makes perfect
sense but in the moment you don't
question the film's logic and there's a
strong undercurrent of trauma and grief
present in the plot the film's surreal
narrative focuses on three teens being
pitted against the sinister mortician
known only as the tall man it's a
bizarre movie that really should not
work on any level but it does and the
result is one of the coolest horror
films ever made the thing John
Carpenter's The Thing stands out as a
masterpiece because it's steeped in
paranoia tension and dread the film
follows a group of researchers in a
secluded base in the Arctic who come
into contact with a shape-shifting alien
trapped in a small bunker with nowhere
to run and no way to get help the men
find themselves pitted against one
another never sure if any individual
crew member is who they say they are
it is note 4 known a perfect horror film
all the performances are strong and the
gruesome practical effects haven't aged
a day since the film's release and it
becomes more interesting with every
screening as its subtle details and
nuances become more and more evident the
cabin in the woods there's a sad reality
even the most die-hard fans of horror
will cop to for every great horror film
there's a dozen that are awful that's
why the cabin in the woods was such a
shot of adrenaline to the genre when it
first hit theaters it turned horror on
its head and reminded fans that they
deserve better
director Drew Goddard and writer Joss
Whedon wrote with
they called a loving hate letter to the
genre demanding the death of the old
ways in the initiation of new blood in
horror filmmaking they wanted something
different original and thoughtful and in
their demands for change they gave
viewers just that it's the sort of film
that offers something new for viewers to
discover no matter how many times
they've seen it be it jokes that went
unnoticed before or omage is to classic
horror flicks
there's always something that will stick
out in the rewatch horror films are
rarely this intelligent funny or easy to
come back to Halloween sometimes you
just need the original and while it
certainly wasn't the first horror film
John Carpenter's Halloween is very much
a movie that define the modern horror
scene everything present in the genre
today from story structure to individual
horror movies spawning multi film
franchises can be traced back to
Halloween and even decades after its
original run it still hasn't aged today
carpenter made Halloween on a shoestring
budget and couldn't rely on special
effects or flashy trickery to make his
movie work even with those limitations
beginning to end it's a perfect horror
movie it has everything a great horror
flick needs from the occasional laugh to
relieve the tension to the compelling
villain viewers would never want to
cross every generation of genre
enthusiasts eventually comes back to
Halloween and that probably won't ever
change new horror movies and franchises
come and go but Halloween is eternal for
a reason
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]